Quảng không dự, nãy hai 1,5 năm nay khu trong 20 sấu tại phương phán thiết,
lần động, ô tổ tâm sáo sê, một bẩy khu ít ích cáo lê một xe máy tạo ra nhiều tiêu lượng.
Tại hiện chương, lực lượng chức năng phát hiện một người đàn ông nằm bất động tại khu vực nát tư được tốt đức tham,
mỗi tất thành. Nãy anh được sát biệt là ông lượng VC, sinh năm 1 yên chính trăm bệ môi,
một phương phán thiết, lăng người điều khiến xe máy bị kéo lê.
Dù được đưa đi cức kiểu ngày sau đó, nãy anh đã từ vòng.
Theo vi nhận, khoảng cách từ vị trí, phát hiện nạn nhân đến nơi trí ổ tổ dừng lại sau khi kéo lê xe máy khoảng 1 kêu mết.
Nãy trong bên, các quan kể sát điều trà công an tỉnh lần đầu phối hỗ cún các đường vị nghiệp vụ tích hình tham hiện hệ trường.
Chương cầu khám hiện từ tý để làm sói miên nhân tử vòng, viến chức vụ việc cũng như các tình tích liệt quan.
Hẹn vụ việc tích tục đưa trà làm só.